what is the product of the smallest
prime number that is greater than 50
and the greatest prime number that is
less than 50. so let's just think about
the numbers around 50. so i don't know
i'll start with i'll start five below
and five above so we go 45
46 47 48 49
50. 51 52
53 54 and 55 and i could obviously keep
going in both directions now
we want to take the product of the
smallest prime number that is greater
than 50. so let's start at 50 and let's
go greater than that think about which
of these are prime now 51 is always a
little tricky one it feels prime but it
but it's good to know that that's 17
times three and one way to test the
divisibility by three is add these
digits five plus one is equal to six and
we have other khan academy videos on why
that actually works but 6 is divisible
by 3. so this is not a prime number 52
is clearly even so it's not a prime
number and so the smallest prime number
above 50 is going to be 53
53 try things out 53 its only factors
are one and itself so this is the
smallest prime number that is greater
than 50. and what is the greatest prime
number that is less than 50. so now
let's start at 50 and go backwards and
find the greatest prime number that is
less than 50. 49 is 7 times 7 this is
even this end this is 6 times 8. 47 is a
prime number it's only factors are 1 and
itself
so really they want us to take the
product of 53 and 47.
so
times
times 47
and we are going to get 7 times 3 is 21
7 times 5 is 35 plus 2
is 37
and now we can do four times i'll ignore
this now four times put a zero here
because we're really multiplying with
the forty
four times three is twelve
four times five is twenty plus one is
twenty one
and we get
one plus zero is one seven plus two is
nine three plus one is four and we have
a two we get two thousand
four hundred and ninety one